well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour then we will see
what's making the headlines with the
columnist and broadcaster carol malone
and the editor of the courier in dundee
david clegg great to see both of you
as ever to the front pages then let us
start with the telegraph
it leads with matt hancock refuting
dominic cummings's claim that he lied
about his
handling of nursing homes in the early
days of the pandemic
you told them they were safe the daily
mirror features the care home residents
who lost their lives
due to the virus the metro accuses the
health secretary
of painting over allegations of having
lied their headline
matt gloss it's also the lead for the
guardian pressure on hancock
over failure to protect care home
residents the eye
leading with the possibility that the
final loosening of restrictions
on june the 21st could be delayed by the
emergence of the indian variant
the daily mail responds to that news
declaring don't
steal our summer while the express
declares that the lifting of all
restrictions next month
hangs in the balance which is also the
main
story in the times
davis paper the courier has word that
the dundee area could be placed back
to level three of scotland's covered
restrictions because of a significant
increase in cases particularly of
the indian variant the financial times
reports that the russian government has
provoked the anger of airlines
by refusing to re-route flight paths to
avoid belarusian airspace
in the wake of the arrest of an
opposition journalist on a ryanair
flight
to the star let's see where have you
been it says it's forecast to be sunny
over the bank holiday weekend
which is the lead for the star which is
just what we need to be fair isn't it
the sun rather than the star at that
point i suppose but anyway a bit of
cheer doesn't hurt anybody
uh carol and david clegg are here um
we'll talk about the indian variant in
in just a moment but first of all
um it's been a rough old day for the
health secretary carol
well i think it's nothing less that he
deserves frankly uh you know his
i thought his i thought he was shocking
today actually i didn't say him in the
comments but
i did say the press conference he gave
today uh and he insulted each and every
one
of of the the people who died and their
families today by
by ducking and diving and dodging the
main question
which was five times he was asked one of
the times was by
your beth rugby five times he was asked
if he promised the pm that all
elderly residents would be tested before
they left hospital and were putting put
back into care homes
and he would not answer what he was
talking about he was rambling on about
he was getting the testing capacity in
place and it wasn't
in place at that time and he even said
this is how you
get things done in government by putting
policies in place
that was not the question he was asked i
mean i was
i'm i'm very lucky in that i haven't
lost anyone
that i love in this crisis but if i had
and it or if i was a care home worker or
running a care home
i would have been incandescent today to
watch this man
squirming around and avoiding the
question say what you like about dominic
coming yesterday he admitted
to his fails he admitted to have met
that he made mistakes
matt hancock seems incapable of that you
know he said today that he's never lied
it's simply not true he has lie he even
lied this week when he was talking about
he said in both that tens of thousands
of people were being vaccinated every
day
the truth was it's the i think this was
three thousand that's official data
so yes he does lie but this the lie
about the care homes
is is vitally important because there
are there
we we think that between 37 and 40 000
elderly people died in cairo
and every one of the families of those
people deserve an explanation
and they didn't get it today with the
accusation david has long been that the
government has over promised
and under under delivered and i suppose
people look at matt hancock and think he
is the
over promiser in chief um the question
is did he just over promise to us or did
he
also over promise to the cabinet and the
prime minister
yes i i listened carefully to dominic
cummings evidence yesterday and i think
there was there's something very
important about what he was saying
it's not just that he lied about uh
well or he had made a declaration that
everyone would be tested before they'd
be discharged privately
he also said that his commitment to do
so many tests so quickly
actually caused problems and made it
more difficult organizationally for the
government
to get the whole testing regime done
properly and i think i think that is a
real issue
and we're it's actually one of those
rare occasions where i'm in complete
agreement with carol
i do think that um his response to that
uh was not appropriate today because it
was a very serious allegation
and whatever you have whatever you think
of dominic [ __ ]
he laid it out in a very calm and i
think
uh compelling way yesterday what went
wrong
and how it must be
scrutinized so that lessons can be
learned from it and that
clearly with the response we had today
that is not going to happen because it
was very difficult not to
scrutinize what happened but to even pin
down with clarity
what happened there was contradictory
accounts and i think that's a real
problem that can't really
be allowed to continue and i think the
other issue that that also brings forth
is
why is the prime minister uh backing his
health secretary
under these circumstances if there is as
we're led to believe documentary
evidence that he was concerned about
this as well
and that matt hancock is now giving a
version of events it doesn't square with
what he said previously
well if your media plan is to sort of
ignore what dominic cummings
said you can't really get rid of your
health secretary can you because because
that would sort of make that back far
but
but carol did jenny harry's give matt
hancock a get out of jail car today by
suggesting that discharge
from hospital was actually a very very
tiny proportional cause of cases
she pointed out what made an impact in
care homes was regular testing of staff
and residents
i suppose the downside of that is that
other countries stopped staff
moving between care homes which we did
not in this country
when you take an elderly person who is
in a hospital
who has coveted and you put them into it
into a care home
it's like putting a bomb in there i mean
jenny harry should not be giving
him excuses you know it's what you just
touched on there you know boris can't be
seen to sack him now because it looks
like
cummings is still calling the shots
inside government and and so he can't
he can't be seen to be sacked at this
moment in time and yet he
and i think cummings is right you know
all the media were looking at what he
was doing over the past year and well we
were calling for him to be sacked
and and the the rumor was boris was
keeping him on so that when the inquiry
came he had escaped verdict a sack of
men
but it's gone beyond that now you know
what david says is true you know
whatever you think about cummings you
might think he's an
he's an arrogant so-and-so but his
evidence was compelling yesterday
i was i was convinced that the man was
telling the truth he has no reason not
to tell the truth and people in the
government who are banging on about
he was trying to get vengeance there
might have been a touch of that but the
bottom line was
this government has to be held
accountable for what's happened yes if
we look at the metrics if i can just
come in quickly anna
because i think there's an important
thing there as an as a newspaper editor
we were aware at the time that this was
a real problem that there was something
going on in care homes and trying to get
the bottom of what was going on then at
the time was really really difficult
there was a wall of silence thrown down
across that
in scotland as well as in england and in
other parts of the united kingdom
and the fact that we're a year on and
we're still in that position is not
acceptable and something really must
change about that yes and scotland was
quite badly hit was it not
uh right at this time with with care
home deaths
um but matt hancock and i think that's
something actually that the scottish
government have questions to answer on
because if you listen carefully to what
dominic cummings said yesterday
he said that they were given this
promise that everyone would be tested
before they were discharged into care
homes but then both the prime minister
and he got sick and when they got back
they found that this disaster had
unfolded
well that was not the case in scotland
it was the scottish government nicholas
sturgeon the first minister in the
health
secretary here that was dealing with
that in scotland so we also need to get
to the bottom of why it seems to have
happened in scotland as well
okay very interesting i mean there's one
thing i would say is that
if these old people stayed in hospital
there is a very high chance they would
have caught covered in hospital with the
influx of patients
you watched wuhan where they were
building hospitals for people
there was a sense of panic that you
needed the bed so where would you have
put these people that's the question
isn't it
what was the nightingale for what was
the nightingale built for exactly that
but you know well it wasn't it wasn't
for that was it it was for covert
patients that was for covert patients
and then it was found this was disease
but you put them into a care home with
uninfected people
who then become infected i mean it's a
kamikaze exercise
and hancock should have known that he
did know that because that's why he
promised the prime minister that what
happened
he knew how dangerous it was but he just
didn't make it happen
and he should be sacked of this i'm
amazed that that boris is still
supported
one of the problems i think another
point about that is that no one is
disputing that these were impossible
decisions that people were facing it was
an incredible
unprecedented situation and there was no
easy answers but what we need to take
from that is
here's what happened here's what what
went wrong and here's the lessons that
we can learn from the future
if people are not being honest and open
about what happened then we have no
chance of getting it better next time
well here's a lesson for you if we look
at the metro in other places matt gloss
um obviously matt hancock's defense is
that the testing simply wasn't available
but what happened in germany well in
early january
they mobilized a national crisis
management effort
and then by the 16th of january they had
developed one of the world's first
diagnostic tests
um by february 300 german labs were
manufacturing it
what happened to us in january february
and most of march
is that it looks like our government
from what mr cummings alleges
had its eye off the ball and that and
that's the bottom line isn't it that
they didn't mobilize fast enough
we didn't take this seriously and that's
this is what cummings said too
that the prime minister was treating it
like it was swine flu that ludicrous
thing he was going to be
injected live on television to show
people that the virus wasn't dangerous i
mean
that shows how they were just not across
this how catastrophically
incompetent they were how how they just
didn't take this virus seriously
until it was too late and it's
interesting there was a guy called
professor john edmunds who you know was
on television yesterday he was backing
up dominic dominic cummings and saying
had we locked down earlier tens of
thousands of lives would have been saved
you know this is decided so boris says
we always follow the signs it's
actually not true he didn't follow the
signs at the beginning of all of this
well punching hard to
to the artist david apologies we're
running out of time i just wanted to
show the daily mirror very quickly which
is punching hard
you told them they were safe showing
some of those who sadly lost their lives
in care homes and
you know family's heartbreak it claims
that hancock lied over care homes
clearly we've just had the allegations
from
mr cummings we know that matt hancock is
before those select committees
on the 10th of june and he will no doubt
give his version
once again his defense then so uh we
will see what happens obviously with
what he has to say
uh to the science and health committee
or committees even
uh coming up could the final loosening
of restrictions on june the 21st be
under threat talking about that after
this
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
don't believe we did home it's pretty
special isn't it i'm stuart ramsey and
i'm sky's chief correspondent
[Music]
[Applause]
we're enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
we saw snatchbots going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked or they were right
we hear shotguns being fired and also
tear gas is being
put around the information
on this could bring down the entire
network not just
in iraq and syria but across the world
[Music]
sort out a controversial
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now carol malone and
david clegg welcome back to both of you
um david let's uh talk about the indian
variant now i know it's on your front
page as well isn't it
but we're going to start if you don't
mind with the eye variant fears
threatened end of lockdown
on the 21st of june i mean it threatens
way more than that in some respects
we've already seen
european nations decide to uh drop the
barricades against
brits again hasn't it haven't they
rather
yes indeed i think we're at a very
dangerous and precarious moment really
and especially with what we were just
discussing before the break with the
mistakes that have been made in the past
when we didn't listen to the science
properly when we were too blase and
gung-ho
and we didn't consider properly what was
going on and what we needed to do in
response to it
i think we're in a real dangerous
situation here that we could do that we
could do that again because
there's it's it's not completely bleak
there is hope
the indian variant is current is clearly
uh spreading
rapidly but we do have the vaccine
program and what
we need to take a little bit of time to
consider now is to what level
the vaccine is having an impact on that
particular variant
what it's doing to hospitalizations and
there's some potentially positive news
coming out regarding that
so i think while this looks like a very
risky situation
it's not it's not it's not completely
bleak and there is still hope that the
june 21 date for england coming out of
lockdown could go ahead as the prime
minister said today
but i think we need to be very careful
that we're listening to the science and
not making
the mistakes that we've made in the last
year again yes
our um our science correspondent thomas
moore actually spoke a little earlier to
us and said actually there are some
promising signs amid the gloom
which is that analysis of 5 600 cases
this is public health england apologies
uh david and you're in scotland
uh cases of the indian variant showed
that 60 were unvaccinated
and just three percent of them were
fully vaccinated
once again fingers crossed showing the
vaccines work clearly second vaccine
much more than the than the first
vaccine which is the the message isn't
it
um daily express though carol boris we
may need to to wait for our freedom
uh and the daily mail don't steal our
summer um
you know effectively saying let's full
steam ahead on this one
but to be fair boris wouldn't be drawn
on that today he was asked whether
um was going to he was going to have to
roll back on the roadmap but he did he
didn't say he refused to say that but
it's interesting that you know you're
talking about the good news
uh a guy called professor tim spector
said the although the indian variant
is dominant it's it's he said it's the
the
the um the national figures remain
unaffected
for hospitals and stuff you know jenny
harris today as well although
they were kind of warning again about it
then they were saying on the other hand
that you know
the average deaths today are about nine
hospitalizations are
very steady they're very very low you
know we've been told time and again that
the indian variant responds to the
vaccines that it's
no more dangerous it might be easier
spread but it's actually no more
dangerous in terms of life-threatening
than than all the other variants so you
know i i think
i think every reason should be helpful